so new york went from this you know such
a violent place that people didn't want
to live there to this amazing city this
jewel our biggest city in some ways our
greatest city
but the trend has reversed in the last
year violent crime has been steadily
rising their shootings in new york city
are up 40
this year rapes in new york last week
were up 125
compared to the last the same period
last year
you know why this is happening bail
reform laws they mean that
violent criminals are quickly released
back onto the streets
nearly half of suspects arrested for
major crimes
are released with no bail according to
the nypd detectives union
last week a judge in brooklyn released
an alleged teen gang member called rakan
wilson
after his fifth arrest for illegally
possessing a firearm
they're trying to take your guns away
because guns are so dangerous they're
not enforcing gun laws on the books
prosecutors didn't even mention the 19
year old's four other gop and open gun
cases he was released without
bail paul digmo has been following new
york city's
decline very carefully he's the
president of nypd's detective
endowment association he joins us
tonight paul thanks so much for coming
on i appreciate it
so you're one of the people who's
dedicated his life to making the city
safe it's
obviously had this sharp and dramatic
turn in the wrong direction
what do you make of it and what do you
attribute it to
well it's definitely uh it's definitely
attributed to the bail reform
and the recent change in laws in the
city council are there embolding the
criminal element
shootings are up crime is up homicides
are up
every crime imaginable is up and the
people in the city
are the ones that are suffering
i just wonder is there a single person
who didn't see this coming
i mean would do you think the people who
made these changes believed that crime
would go down
when they made them well you know i
think they were just uh riding the wave
uh
what was popular and they weren't doing
what was in the best interest
of the people of the city of new york
you know tucker i have some numbers here
for you if you don't mind
i just want to tell you murders uh 2019
there were 319 murders 2020 there were
462.
shooting incidents in 2019 777
almost 1600 in in 2020 shooting victims
in 2019 920 almost
1900 in 2020 gun arrests by new york
city detectives and police officers
we had 3292
in 2019
and almost 4300 in 2020.
so that's what's going on in the city
it's terrible what's going on
and it's the fault of the elected
officials there's a correlation between
the bail reform
and what's happening in our city
it seems so clear that it is and to
destroy the country's finest police
department is
is a crime i think on its own paul i
appreciate coming on tonight good luck
there thank you